anwalt luca und herzlich willkommen wir
heute zu einer neuen episode nicht
lachen zusammen mit haben die volkswirte
schöne schutzgas weil die fräse
tatsächlich umzusetzen was haben viel
beigebracht auf was man achten soll wenn
man den schulen geht alles kann sein
[Gelächter]
wir verstehen glaube ich den sinn einer
nicht lachen teile strenge es jetzt an
ok aus münchen und die menschen gewöhnt
wie man normale leute aus münchen wo
kommst du her also hier aufnehmen können
jetzt wird sie mir durch sein mag dich
nicht störe das gehör
nein keine angst
dazwischen sorgte und die auch mein pony
heran was ist daraus geworden ist nicht
nur mit acht oder so
[Musik]
die gemeinden erfolgen
aber ich habe mir alles hilft verdient
alle mitstreiter sollen da muss doch gar
nicht mehr geben hier schauen sie mal
das ist doch übertreiben die extras oder
sind das wirklich solche hampelmänner
der melone auf dem kopf fallen so machen
wie immer muss zu übertreiben mit mir
hast du schon mal auf nach russischen
hochzeit und ist das bei euch auch so
ein bisschen anders und ein bisschen
anders aber es ist schon sehr zäh zum
sprachenlernen dadurch war ehrlich
gesagt noch nie auf einer hochzeit
dann bist du auf meiler
der mülltonne oder wasser
ja die sache aber gibt es schönes spiel
und einem frisch gezapften an diesem
nein ich gebe mich ja auch alternative
vorbei wer direkt einkünfte spießig
höhere alter ich finde es zu meckern
[Musik]
[Applaus]
immer dieses mit dem lara wussten wir
zehn jahren teilweise kein essen mehr um
1000 zu kaufen
kein essen hatte keiner fährt wieder
gesagt ihr hattet ja teilweise auch kein
essen mehr um toast brot zu kaufen als
wird man zu essen gegen essen tauschen
nehmen sagt ha ha das lässt doch jeder
kann kanzler von antworten das kann
stimmen denn wenn es jeder wissen würde
würde ich es auch wissen und deswegen
finde ich deine aussage sehr dubios josi
da wenn ich mit ihr gesehen so an flexen
bin mit wörtern und ich da diese eine
riesige hallen von abercrombie & fitch
alter sondern die firma nachspielen das
heißt das kann nicht stimmen denn dennis
jeder wissen würde dann würde ich es
auch müssen deswegen finde ich deine
aussage sehr dubios 13 bis 8
mich stören immer so immer so immer wenn
so hundebesitzer sagen acht der will nur
spielen der bei sich oder so das erste
was er macht es nicht spielen wollen ja
und mein hund beißt auch was sagt dein
hund ja mein hund kennt doch den ganzen
tag
ja und wenn wir den auf hektar
meisterlich ich dachte er liebt dich
liebe zu zeigen
ich liebe zu zeigen ist es euch
gegenseitig zu beißen und du weißt den
hund dann auch naja okay weil jetzt
kombiniert des coaches link lasse ich
das halt die presse ist anders hätte mir
klicks bringen
[Musik]
halt die fresse du sollst einfach nur
dasitzen damit es mehr clique bringen
wenigstens ehrlich sparte tesa das
kapital bis yoga und ich habe immer ein
drucker was ist eigentlich die mission
von miguel pablo
34 videos gesehen und ich habe kein
bisschen gefunden das ist doch zum
schauspiel auf wunsch bestellt wir haben
einfach schlimm die gesehen ist einfach
er war das wirklich schön wie das bisher
wieder du wieso es werden wärst du wenn
die frage gestellt werden würde ein jahr
keines oder ein jahr kein wodka oder
würde ich sagen ein ja kein ja natürlich
auch vermutet eigentlich müssen wir
zusammen uns auf die suche begeben nach
den missionen von prinz marcus von
anhalt und miguel pablo wie wandern
sondern durch durch die wälder und über
die seen und sohn dann müssen wir
wirklich einfach nur die mission finden
von prinz marcus von einem gelungen sein
anders sieht und sagt das ist unser ziel
für 2010 wie dürftig raus ausgangs
beschränkungen wieder so eine andere
alltag
auch mit amg das auto fit bist du seine
die du fliegst ja auch öfters mal in die
türkei dieses jahr wahrscheinlich nicht
aber müsste dann so eine die sich dann
auch so fade wie sachen kauft und so
kommt auch so real madrid trikot mit
müller hinten raus gefälschte vitor
gekauft ehrlich war was für eine logik
wie tausende handtasche oder wie so ein
kleiner geldbeutel aber ganz nach zwei
tagen
diese leute dann in diesen ländern die
das verkaufen sie doch immer so bei
normalerweise 1000 aber für dich heute
neue leute und das 95 euro günstiger
wird besiegt und mir heute sehr original
sehr nahe ich habe nur originell ist es
nochmal der song gewesen
ich habe noch keinen film dauert geguckt
doch das verstehst du jetzt wieder nicht
du hast das geld ist nicht gekommen
das ist eine schauspielerin von haus des
geldes und ja das ist blöd dass dieser
cup serie war der täter mit der
präsentation und server lewis auch
heftig also eine richtige sandra gute
zeit mehr präsentation alois halten
ich verstehe wie alter wenn du dich für
ein kleidungsstück entscheiden müsstest
du dürftest es haben egal wie teuer egal
was es ist was willst du jetzt aussuchen
ich für mir valencia triple es glaube
ich jemand foto wie sandra mit valencia
triple holen würde man schon manchmal
habe ich das heute wieder ist allerdings
auch beendet meine lieben freunde wenn
euch die heutige nicht lachen challenge
mit sandra gefallen hat dann das gerne
einen daumen hoch unter dem video das
schreibt uns gerne in die kommentare auf
was wir nächste woche eventuell
reagieren sollen vielleicht habt ihr ja
irgendwie auch volker hoff ich bin mal
wieder auch darauf hätte ich auch wieder
burg ich wollte gerade sagen ob die
leute vielleicht mal wieder bock auf
hilf mir hätten ihr findet jetzt hier
auf jeden fall ein smiley eingeblendet
wenn ihr darauf könnte meinen kanal
kostenlos abonnieren dadurch verpasse
keine videos mehr zeit hammer damit ihr
so einen geistreichen geistig krank ich
geld egal hier ist die letzte nicht
lachen scheinen schmidt sandra verlinkt
schaut ihr euch gerne an sandra das
letzte wort